hey everyone uh I'm excited to go last
because I have a slide on motivation but
I think the last three talks uh really
kind of drove the point home so thanks
for coming to my talk uh package
management for data
scientists just as an introduction my
name is Tyler fthy I'm an engineering
manager at posit working on the package
manager product I'm also a member of the
r Consortium working group for
repositories and I have about a decade
of software engineering experience I
also started data science running into a
lot of the problems that were discussed
today so as an overview I'll go through
some motivation in scope we'll talk
software package Basics I'll go through
a couple challenges Solutions and ways
to prevent those challenges from
appearing in the first place finally
we'll end with some key
takeaways so if you've ever lost your
mind installing package dependencies in
a new environment and things blow
up running an old script and you get a
little
frustrated um hearing it works on my
machine by maybe a cooworker and then
you can't get it running this talks
probably for you so just for scope and
focus um these are going to be language
agnostic challenges and solutions but
the examples will be in R and
python challenges are typically not
unique to one language but the good
thing is that means that neither are the
solutions or the approaches we could
take to those challenges
and finally I'm just going to use
package Library dependency
interchangeably because once you try to
figure out what is what in different
languages it gets a little
chaotic so what is a package uh the way
I kind of Define a package is it's an
encapsulated piece of code or software
these are shared or installed to enhance
or extend existing functionality so in R
you use install. packages in Python you
might use pip install or cond or pip B
um have a lot more
options and then some examples we use
ggplot 2 to create graphs and
plots and requests to make HTTP
requests so to make sure everyone's on
the same page we install a package using
install. packages we use a library
command in R to import a package and
then we can use that package in our code
to run the functions in this case
creating a scatter plot same thing in
Python we install a package this happens
at the command line in Python using pip
we can import that package and then we
can use it in our code so the first
challenge that I want to talk about is
the conflicting versions challenge um we
talked about this a little bit with
snapshots but uh packages generally use
other packages so this is an example of
a dependency tree um it's a little dated
but the concepts are still there say we
want to install some package we call
that a direct
dependency that package just like we
want to enhance our software it wants to
enhance itself and not have to do all
the little things so it has indirect
dependencies the thing that we really
want to focus on here is packages that
have many lines going to them so those
are packages with a number of reverse
dependencies like we see down here in
the bottom so with that
information uh we can look at a
conflicting versions example so
say we have package a and that relies on
some version of rcpp call it
1.0.6 this is all good and dandy until
we want package
B which requires rcpp
1.0.7 so that probably W won't work but
what should we do here we can say we'll
just always use rcpp 1.0.6 for package a
and we'll use 1.0.7 for package b a lot
of languages won't actually allow that
but even if they did it would be pretty
hard to manage we could potentially
upgrade package a but that will depend
if the author has actually upgraded
package a in GitHub or on crayon and
then we could try downgrading package B
but you run into the same problem that
author might not have a version that
works with rcpp
1.0.6 so the fictitious example comes
from stack Overflow um I found this
annotation Hub installation of rcpp
1.0.6 is already loaded but you know you
need
1.0.7 so looking at the solutions from
stack
Overflow uh first one user recommended
using RM um that ended up working for
the the person who R ran into the issue
but um at the end of the day that was
just downgrading annotation
Hub the next user said update all of the
installed packages delete all of your
other files create a new environment and
that solves your
problem I don't know if you want to do
that every single time um and then same
thing upgrade R which is basically a new
environment and then everything should
work for you again when you install all
your packages so we should know how to
solve these things but we should learn
to prevent them in the first place and I
have RM on this slide but maybe it
should say slushy
um we should use tools to create
reproducible environments so we have RM
vlock um we have requirements. txt and
Python and then we should use snapshots
for package installation so mini cran is
one r package that you can use to grab
subsets of cray bander snatch is one in
Python and then um it was mentioned a
couple times previously but we also have
the pait public package manager if you
haven't seen that before this is what
the View kind of looks like as you're
selecting a snapshot that you want to
always install packages from this works
really well in the our ecosystem because
those packages on any given date are
more likely to be compatible with one
another and then it works really well in
Python because if a package is randomly
deleted from pii which happens sometimes
when authors get mad then you also get
those so the next challenge I want to
talk about are system
dependencies um like packages also use
other packages packages also use other
software so you can have r that relies
on pyth Pyon using reticulate you can
have R and python that rely on a bunch
of different uh pieces of software so
your python code might only work on
Windows your rcode might only work with
a specific version of
C++ um python might require open SSL
whatever it is and so this can make it
pretty hard to move these things
around so as an example again say we
want to install the cryptography package
in
Python so we run pip install
cryptography and then we get some
esoteric error that we don't have
something
installed so what should we do now we
can Google how do you install GCC and
then try this command again and hope it
works we can try to find a binary that's
pre-installed and maybe that will solve
our problem
um and this again comes from stack
Overflow I actually found a ton of these
um and then looking at the Solutions if
you're on Windows you'll need to make
sure you have op SSL
installed for Debian or auntu you need
to run some other
command and there were more solutions
for Mac OS Ral Fedora Raspberry Pi
Etc so again we can prevent this from
happening in the first place we can use
tools to easily manage and recreate
environments we can use cond Docker pitm
even workbench works for this um we you
can use pre-compiled binaries when
possible so pii will serve Wheels which
differ by package so some packages will
have pre-compiled wheels and other
packages won't crayon generally serves
our packages built for Windows and Mac
OS um our universe also serves packages
built for Windows and Mac OS public
package manager adds some Linux
distributions but in some of these cases
we still need system dependencies
installed for things to work so there's
no kind of Silver Bullet here
that's all I wanted to do in terms of
challenges today um if you want to dig
deeper I have a blog post called
challenges and package management I put
the uh public package manager URL there
and then if you really kind of want to
get into the nitty-gritty um I watched
this talk called how can package
managers handle ABI in compatibility in
C++ and that that was pretty intense so
check it out um terms of
takeaways every time you create a new r
or python script you should also create
a lock file of requirements.txt
um you know if you get used to this then
you're not going to run into that thing
where six months later you try to run
code and nothing works again um consider
looking at tools like Docker to handle
environments and avoid some of those
other
problems and then if you're a package
author Define your versions and system
dependencies for others so whenever you
see this I want you to be
asking where's my lock
file cool thank
you thanks Tyler uh we do have some time
for questions uh again it's slido uh can
we put the yeah pause it with slido dasb
there for Ballroom B um one question
here is what do you recommend for
package Management in an air gapped
environment that is needed for working
with sensitive
data um well package manager Works in an
air gaed environment so that would
probably be my first but thanks for
setting that one up for us yeah uh mini
cran and I think bander snatch also work
if you're just working in either our um
Python and you need something easy you
can download
those any other questions that people
have you can just raise your hand at
this point you'd like
to
sure
yeah that's a good question I mean I
think whenever you're making um
decisions around locking and how
permissible to be in terms of
requirements you really have to look at
how sensitive is your data how worried
are you about you know vulnerabilities
and those sorts of things um and if you
just really want things to work in six
months you know I would pin to a
specific version and then you you know
you can add tests and as tests pass you
can try to like like GitHub now has the
um dependabot that will look at versions
and upgrade them and so at least you can
get some workflow to confirm that things
are still working instead of just
relying that the package is going to
work six months later or
something in my in my experience at
least in the r world it's been fairly
common that people just do greater than
or equal to at at the one that works
right and typically that's the cran
version it does seem slightly more
common in the python world that people
will either pin to a specific version or
will sometimes pin down to like a
previous version if they know that the
new one somehow doesn't work with their
thing um that does cause some issues
though so anyone
else okay thanks so much Tyler cool
thanks
[Applause]
everyone